hello everyone uh i hope you enjoyed my
coverage of game one and game two from
this match if you did you're definitely
gonna enjoy game three
and for those of you who are maybe new
to this channel uh i do suggest you
check out my coverage of the 1959
candidates tournament first before
watching this series
as you will enjoy it a lot more it's the
first thing you'll see in the
description below there's a link to
to my playlist of the 1959 candidates uh
so feel free to check it out
now about this game uh this is game
three of the match doll versus bot
finick and
tal was very interested to see as he is
now in the lead in the match they he won
the first game drew the second
and will bottom go for the win with the
black pieces and if so what
opening will he use or will he wait for
his chances
when he will have the white pieces so
a lot of things to consider here and
they they really
again had no idea what botunic would try
uh they thought if botvinnik would go
for a win he would definitely repeat
the french defense from game one and
maybe improve on that game
he will definitely not go for the
sicilian as you don't want to play
sicilian against stal
so basically they knew that he would go
for the karo khan and
tal had something very specially
prepared for this game
uh so let's see it uh tal opens with e4
and we have c6 by botvinnik the karo
khan defense
knight to c3 d5 and now knight to f3
uh botanic goes for bishop to g4 and
botvinnik had this position on the board
plenty of times during his world chess
championship matches
uh even with with the vaseline's missile
of uh
so talgo's h3 this is all standard all
seen before
uh both unique plays bishop captures on
g3 and here on move 5
tal already plays a novelty he plays g
captures on f3
and tal was extremely criticized about
this move creating such a weakness
straight out of the opening against the
botvinnik in the world chess
championship match
but tal didn't want to play queen
characters on f3 as botanic already
played this position plenty of times he
knew
all the ins and outs of this variation
so he decided uh to create some
weaknesses in his own camp
but uh he said that this does strengthen
white's center
uh he does gain the open g file for the
rook maybe a moves like h4
rook to h3 bringing the rook to g3 will
be possible in the future
and another thing is the psychological
aspect of this move now botvinnik uh
has the has to play real chess he can't
uh really just
go about uh his opening preparation uh
because botvinnick was known to be a
home preparation master
but as you'll see in this game botfinic
is not one to scare easily
about novelties in the game uh and the
one thing tal really hopes to take
advantage of is
now that this does create an open game
is the advantage of his bishop pair so
let's see how tall
uses all of these uh all of these uh
ideas we have e6 by botvinnik and
that's an interesting move uh had he go
for e5
this would then really be an open game
and then the bishop
pair would definitely have the advantage
so he closes it up e6
we have d4 by tal and now knight to d7
and here tao plays bishop to f4 and
bishop to f4 was not
in tal's home preparation uh in his home
preparation uh bishop to e3 was an idea
followed by queen d2
castling queenside uh this is an
improvement
tal found over the board so he
disregarded his opening preparation and
went for bishop to be to f4
uh and botunic really takes care of this
move he plays
bishop to b4 uh with the idea that if
tal continues with a3 of course botanic
will retreat with bishop to a5 followed
by bishop to c7 at the counter tells the
strong bishop on f4
so here tile played h4 and this h4
is well in a match like this it could be
considered a blunder
he considered botanic's next move but
the variation he was preparing
uh in the end tal saw that it it simply
doesn't work
uh botanic played knight the g to f6 and
here tal's idea
was a3 a3 with a very long variation
which after calculating it uh for for
for a long time
uh tells audit it simply doesn't work
tal's idea was
a3 and after bishop captures on c3 b
captures on c3
uh d captures an e4 pawn captures on f4
and now
knight captures on f4 thal's idea was
queen to f3
attacking the knight uh queen to a5 uh
now if queen captures knight
uh then queen captures on c3 and picks
up the rook
uh so rook to h3 preparing queen
captures on e4 and now
knight d to f6 and here tal's idea was
h5 with the idea that if both winnie
castles queen side
now h6 uh g captures an h6
bishop to e5 now with a double attack on
the knight
now knight to g5 attacking the queen and
the rook and
this was the idea of tal's variation
queen captures on f6
uh giving up the exchange so knight
captures on h3 and now king to d2
defending the c3
pawn uh knight back to g5 uh
bishop to d3 and tal calculated all the
way to here and he saw
that white with the bishop pair and in a
let's say a semi-open game will will
have compensation for the exchange
uh but then he saw the horror of his
calculation bottoming can play queen
captures on e5
and here it also that his position is
simply lost
uh of course you can't capture the queen
because knight to f3
attacks the queen also checks the king
problem is you can't capture with the
pawn with the d-pawn because knight the
e4 now checks the king and forks the
queen the bishop is pinned
so if this happened tal would have to
play something like queen captures but
after king captures
and d captures on e5 uh both when he has
knight of three check
king moves picks up the pawn and with a
better pawn structure and two extra
pawns
this is simply a winning game for
botunic so unfortunately for tal his uh
home preparation
maybe did give him a positional
advantage but
his bishop to f4 idea over the board
uh not really so
after knight g to f6 uh saw that a3
doesn't work so he had to play e5 and
here uh
he he felt he said he felt defeated that
this game was not positionally lost
because e5 closes the position
and tal will no longer be able to take
advantage of the bishop pair
so knight to h5 bishop to g5
we have queen to a5 attacking the knight
on c3 twice
bishop back to d2 and now queen to b6
we have a3 bishop back to e7 bishop to
e3 now by tal
and g6 uh g6 would with a brilliant idea
by botunic he wants to improve the
position of his knight
playing knight to g7 followed by knight
to f5 and
the knight will be extremely strong on
f5 only way
tal could get rid of it as he he doesn't
really have a g pawn or d pawn to get
rid of it
would be to give up his light square
bishop but then really
tal has nothing because tal was really
trying to
trying to gain some advantage by using
his bishop pair in an open game
so tal tries knight to a4 he wants to
create some complications
and invites botunic to play queen to a5
but
botvinnik isn't interested in any
complications he just enjoys his
superior position he plays queen back to
d8
uh queen to d2 and now knight to g7
preparing knight
f knight f5 uh tao plays
bishop to g5 hoping uh for both winning
the capture so he can open up the h file
uh but here botanic simply plays h6 and
tal sees now that his position is just
terrible
uh if tal were to to capture the bishop
for example bishop captures queen
casters
uh there's really nothing to hope for in
this position with white
if you if you try and exchange queens
your end game is
is simply really bad b6 captures
captures and the black's position is
so much superior so after this
h6 move tal has to accept the pawn
sacrifice although it's only a temporary
pawn sacrifice bishop captures
uh knock on knight to f5 with a double
attack on the bishop
bishop moves and now rook captures on h4
uh
rook captures knight captures and here
botanic is already threatening
knight to f3 uh checking the king
forking the queen
and tal decided to castle here just give
up the f3 pawn because trying to defend
it
would run into a lot of trouble due to
bishop to g5
and you can't you can grab the bishop
because the tactics work in botonic's
favor if bishop captures simply queen
captures
queen captures and knight f3 check again
picks up the queen
so tal decided to give it up it's a
double death pawn no no point protecting
it tal castle queen side
uh botwink doesn't bother himself with
with the pawn he plays b5
and his idea is basically your only move
is knight to c3 after you play this the
black can either play queen to a5 and
start the attack
uh he can push a5 this is this is just
an amazing position for black
but here it also that if he does that he
can
just give up the game so instead uh tal
found
one way uh to maybe open up the position
and make use of the bishop pair
that played knight to c4 knight to c5 he
decided to sacrifice one more pawn
but maybe to open up the position so
botvinnik accepted
knight captures on c5 d captures on c5
and now
bishop captures on c5 and here bishop to
e2 simply guarding that f3 pawn
uh bishop to e7 tau plays king to b1
and a very important move as this bishop
if
if it ever comes to the g5 it could
really harass the queen and the king on
c1
uh queen to c7 uh and now comes
rook to h1 botany goes for the queenside
castle and now bishop to g3 attacking
the knight
knight to f5 attacking the bishop and
here rook to h7
with the idea that if
knight captures the bishop tal will
undouble his pawns and
he'll he will be pressuring this f7 pawn
and here it was a it was really
the time pressure for both finnick and
he had to decide
how to deal with this uh he played rook
to f8
tal's idea is uh that bishop to c5 would
be better activating this bishop
uh then the queen would be guarding the
f7 pawn rook can come to
d7 to add more protection uh but uh
in some time trouble bottoming decided
to guard it with
rook to f8 and this gives stahl some
chances now
now tells the idea is pretty simple he
plays bishop to f4
he doesn't allow both unique to capture
his bishop removing his bishop pair
and now his idea is simply bishop to d3
capture the knight on f5 and bishop to
h6
uh getting rid of this awkwardly placed
rook
so uh queen to d8 by botunik and this
was
actually actually botonic's idea of rook
to rook this rook to f8
uh thug was bishop to d3 continuing with
his plan but now
rook to h8 and this was bought phoenix
id all along
uh now you have to exchange rooks if you
play rook captures on f7 queen eight
uh you lose the rook uh well the
exchange of course you're not just gonna
leave the rook there
uh so tal had to capture it rook
captures queen captures and now
queen to a5 and this queen to a5 is the
only move that
allows stal to stay in the game
uh queen to a5 because now the queen
doesn't have time to get back
to help out with the defense because
queen captures on a7
is coming if both finish decided to
defend
this with king the b7 then tal would
simply play bishop captures on b5
and botanic can no longer achieve
anything here c captures queen captures
and
the king cannot escape
repetition by draw because tal will
simply continue checking him
if he moves queen a6 check if he moves
again uh then tal can even grab the a7
pawn and have
three pass pawns on the queen side it's
not something you want to do so probably
in this position botswink would settle
for a draw
but after queen a5 bottomix still wants
to win this game he plays queen to h1
check
king to a2 and now queen captures on f3
uh tal plays queen a6 check we have king
to b8 and now
uh botvinnik is attacking uh tells
bishop on f4
uh but tal sees that there's no point in
doing anything about this here tao plays
queen captures on c6
he gives up the bishop with one simple
idea both unique captures it and here
tau plays bishop captures on b5 and this
is amazing about
tal's play if you remember that position
like
15 moves ago tal had totally undeveloped
bishops the position was totally close
he couldn't do anything with his bishop
pair
and now botunic is a piece up but tal is
threatening bishop to a6
and there will be no defense against
queen to b7 checkmate
so that's really something to learn from
i mean he was so uh
there was nothing he could do but when
he really tied him down and then
he tried he tried he tried he gave up a
little material and now
uh it seems like he's about to win the
game
so there is only one move that saves the
bot finick here and the bot finick plays
it that's
queen captures on e5 now bishop to a6
will be met with queen to c7
protecting against checkmate and if
queen 28 then queen can
simply come to d8 defending so uh
here queen 28 by tal this comes with
check
we have king to b7 and it was in this
position that
tal spent most most of the time uh
spent probably all of the time on his
clock he was really left
with only a little time he was
calculating bishop to a6 check
so sacrificing even another piece uh
to bring the king over to the a file
because any move other than capturing
the bishop
uh will be followed by queen c8 and then
the black king is getting checkmated
now the problem is after king captures
an a6 tal does have
queen to c6 and the king has to go down
down the board
uh king to a5 and here you don't have b4
to check mate uh
sorry uh to check made the black king
because bishop can capture it and this
will be good for black
but after we play c3 now b4 is
definitely a threat
of checkmate but queen to e2 and went
also the screen to e2 idea he saw that
the b pawn is pinned there's no way to
continue this uh but
there's really no way for white to lose
this game i mean
if if if played precisely it would
probably end up in a draw
uh but it could give some practical
chances uh for tal to win the game
as black has to be really careful but uh
calculated this variation he almost lost
on time so he decided
as the quote above the board says he
does not won't attempt
fate as he was so bad for for the entire
game
uh so after this king to b7 move uh tal
played
queen to c6 check and here after king to
b8
uh they agreed to a draw so game 3 also
ended in a draw but
you know a lot of fireworks and a lot of
hidden variations that were never
actually seen on the board
this is what happens when two very very
strong players play
but i do hope you enjoyed it as out of
the first three games i do have to say
this is
my favorite uh we'll see we'll see what
what else happens in this
world chess championship and it's a very
interesting uh idea how tall
sacrificed little by little just to
activate his bishop pair
so yeah uh i do hope you enjoyed it once
again if you're new to this channel
check out
my coverage of the 1959 candidates
tournament the link will be in the
description below
uh i would like to thank an anonymous
person joshua gilly matthew little
jason co and richard sand for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon uh with on game four
of the 1960 world chess championship
match
thank you all and i will see you soon